des colonnes d'autobus de véhicules de
l'onu des membres de la croix rouge
internationale
des civils évacués
de présumer retrouvailles ces images de
l'armée russe ne donne aucune
information sur la date de ses possibles
évacuations de mario paul
après des semaines de siège c'est une
ville fantôme que les russes et les
séparatistes contrôle au milieu des
ruines ceux qui ont décidé de rester
tentent de survivre c'est le cas de
christina bourdiaux pharmacienne et mère
de deux enfants
j'ai commencé à regarder les cadavres
des explosions avec plus de calme j'ai
compris comment les gens vivent en syrie
ou dans d'autres pays dit elle c'est
très très effrayant
pour l'instant comme les autres
résidents elle peut compter sur cetet
d'alimentaire frappé d'un z symbole de
l'invasion russe en ukraine pour
survivre
christine cherche un emploi celui qu'on
lui propose c'est de trier les décombres
de sortir les cadavres de déminer pour
32 mille roubles par mois l'équivalent
de 450 dollars
pour la famille vos rôti l'ina il
fallait quitter marioupol coûte que
coûte en rafistolant leurs voitures lada
ravagé par les bombardements
la mère ses deux filles et leurs chiens
sont arrivés sains et saufs à asa
porridge ya aussi
la seule chose qui m'importait était la
sécurité de mes enfants de tous les
enfants
pour le ministre des affaires étrangères
ukrainien rien ne garantit la réussite
de ces évacuations
à odessa c'est un autre bâtiment qui
s'est effondré ce port stratégique de la
mer noire et sous les bombes russe
depuis des semaines
alors que l'armée ukrainienne affirme
avoir détruit deux bateaux patrouilles
russes au large de l'île aux serpents à
l'omnium de cette guerre est aussi celle
des mots les propos tenus dimanche par
le chef de la diplomatie russe on tue
l'effet d'une bombe son enfant - module
tobo l'hitler avait aussi du sang juif
avait-il déclaré
des propos condamnés par la communauté
internationale et par le président
céline ce qui est méchante celui qui dit
qu'il n'y a pas de mots assez forts pour
dénoncer le plus haut diplomate russe
qui blâment le peuple juif pour les
crimes nazis
au 68e jour de l'invasion de l'ukraine
moscou annonce que la guerre ne prendra
pas fin à la date symbolique du 9 mai
jour de la victoire la russie continue à
grignoter du terrain dans l'est du pays
et à pilonner les civils ici s
mitraillette radio canada montréal